hi so my name is professor bruces
i'm associate professor in the
department of biomedical
engineering at stony brook university so
first i want to thank the organizers for
the opportunity to present some of our
work today and
my goal here is twofold first i want to
re
tell you about the story of this project
that
led us from single cell encapsulation
to digital pcr platform that could be
applied to
detect saskatoon v2 and read the the
second aim is really to share my
enthusiasm for microfluidics
and to try to convey and highlight the
creativity involved in the
development of microfluidic systems
so storybook university is located on
long island
close to new york city and you can see
we got like
over 26 000 students
uh including like 17 000 undergrads and
about 1500 faculties
the biomedical engineering department is
really a joint department between the
college of engineering of
uh and applied sciences and the
department of storybook medicine
so i'm basically my lab is uh
called microflex for quantitative
engineering biology
what we have been developing in the past
a few years is really a way
i mean we really focus on how to
manipulate
a single particle thing of cells in a
very passive
way the impetus for that is really to
develop
new systems to analyze single cell
but three single cell are at a time
so in conventional methods like you can
see here
when you measure a parameter across
all cell population which you obtain is
average
measurements while if you can measure
the same parameter
cell by cell across that population what
you get is the distribution of this
parameter
across the cell population and there is
a lot of application
where that type of information is
critical
one simple example is cancer where one
one bad apple if we can say so when
cancer cells can give rise to a tumor
so that is really important to get this
fine description
of cell subpopulation it's also true in
developmental biology in brain
science and so on and so forth now
what we're interested in really is we
are more interested in genomic analysis
of
single cells
and my technology technology of choice
is really droplet microfluidics that i
contributed to develop while i was
working for raindance technologies
in this technology samples are
partitioned in small droplets
and routed and manipulated through
macrophage channels
at very high throughput right so
this actually technology is typically
had as high throughput or very high
throughput technology
because droplets can be generated and
manipulated at
thousands of droplets per second
now when i went back to academia i
looked at the single cell genomics field
and noticed the discrepancy between a
throughput of triplet microfluidics
and the capacity of consequences with a
few thousands
of single cells per ram which is still
the case today
so i decided to focus on what i call
pressured samples
such as biopsies and
retool droplet microfluidics for the
purpose of analyzing this type of
samples
where with the idea is to trade
throughput for higher degree of control
and the first thing to basically
uh the first aspect to address is the
fact that
singles encapsulation is limited by
personal statistics one thing i haven't
mentioned i agree droplet
microflex is really a very attractive
way to manipulate samples from
microfluidic channels because there is
no dispersion all your
the content may is maintained within
that droplet right so
again a single cell encapsulation is one
of the limitations
because it's dictated or limited by
person statistics if you see in this
video
single cells come in into the nozzle get
encapsulated
but the true statistics within the draw
plots
is what you see on the left uh
bottom left side right the graph
and that graph corresponds to one
cell per droplet all right the
concentration of cells coming in
is once a per droplet but what you get
in reality is the distribution you see
in
orange at the bottom left here is that
one third of the drops
are empty one fur contains one droplets
or one single cell and the rest of the
droplets contain
more than one single cell right now if
you want to have true single cell
encapsulation
i mean or at least single cell
encapsulation
you have to dilute your sample at this
10 fold
and you obtain the blue distribution
where all the droplets contain a cell
contain only a single cell
but then you got 90 percent of the
droplets
that remain empty and that's
one of the uh big limitations
so to address this limitation we
developed what we call the trapping and
encapsulation strategy
so the first step we trap single cells
into chambers
then the second step is to throw oil
around those chambers
and we're going to see in details how
that works
to create three droplets right we've got
a amount of
volume of liquid here of aqueous liquid
basically um
immersed within oil so that's a droplet
and the third step was to retrieve those
droplets by throwing
oil from the other side
so the first step is really to trap so
how does that work
when you've got uh you have to consider
the module here you've got the chamber
you see that it's connected to the main
channel through a very small
uh channel and the whole idea is that
when the cell comes in
and the device re i mean it's designed
so that the
next cell comes in it's going to plug
that small channel
right so that there is no flow through
that chamber
and the following cell is going to go
around that's what you see in this
in this schematic so this is a theory
that's designed
for but the question is like what's the
efficiency of this
approach and in other words if we inject
100 cells how many can we trap
and here we can see a time lapse uh
that this basically highlights the
trapping trajectories
we can see in the first panel on the
left the cell comes in
in the first chamber and the second
channel
the second cell comes around the first
chamber and goes get trapped into the
second channel and again in the third
channel the third cl
goes around the first chamber goes on
the second and gets into the third
channel
so that's really the principle at work
here
so but again how many cells can we trap
you can see the video here that displays
exactly the same idea
here we focus on the next empty chamber
and the next one and so on and so forth
and that's really how we quantified
so we looked at the first empty chamber
and we looked if the next cell would
get in or whether it would get in the
next
second to next right so and what we
observe is like we've got
almost 94 percent of the cells we're
going to
next available trap or chamber
and about 5.6 percent go to the
next plus one okay and the rest will go
next plus one plus one
so the chopping efficiency is very very
good
uh we can say it's 100 percent
and you can see in this video here
so now the encapsulation the
encapsulation really
harnessed the idea that the cell plugs
this small
channel right when we push oil the oil
cannot go
through the chamber but it has to go
around
as well so the result was not as good as
trapping but still 86 of
single cells were trapped when there
were fixed cells while 78
when they were live cells
now the third step is with droplet
retrieval by
injecting all from the outlet we can
retrieve those droplets
containing single cells bring them to
other modules to
process their content
so the take-home message of this project
that was the first design
that was published a few years ago is
really it's a passive method right
it's all it's all like all the cells are
manipulated
through uh through basically flow
it's all passive there's no like
actuators
electric field nothing just flow
we don't get any empty droplets per
principle
the droplet volume does not depend on
the cell size but on the
chain the volume of the chamber itself
and once trapped cells can be observed
right and our idea is really to
combine those observations with some
genomic profile and
perform like multi-dimensional analysis
of single cells
now what can we learn from encapsulation
faders so here this is time lapse
right in this column from top to bottom
it's over time
and the oil goes from top to bottom as
well so in the very
top panel what we see is like the all
commands
coming in and we got this interface
so the interface is going to snap off
but if you observe what's happening with
the cell
you can see that it gets squeezed in
through the uh
channel very thin channel and get
expelled through it
once expelled basically all the content
of the
uh that is in the chamber is going to be
expelled as well
so that's how it fails and basically
what happens it's like here in the
schematic
again the o comes in creates a higher
pressure
that is going to create some flow around
the cell if
there is a little bit of leakage and
that is going to deform the cell and
push it out
so what we realized really when it's
basically efficient or like effective is
that
the encapsulation is complete when the
front of oil
reaches that small channel here
and cuts it off here is that okay
after that the system inside
the the chamber is re-frozen
and our idea was okay why don't we
then cut off this channel first
in other words why can't we inject the
oil from the outlet
cut off the small capri
channel and go around and and complete
the encapsulation process
so the all we can
cut off the small capability channel
without getting in
thanks to capri evolving
now there's an issue with that approach
it's called full reversibility right we
push the cells in
like this it gets strapped but now if
you push all from the outlet we're going
to push the cells out again
so again our first naive idea was okay
let's
create a secondary capture putting a
hook
on the way out
now if we really look at the trapping
principle here is
uh we to understand how things work and
how we can we can re
address all those issues at once
so here you've got the chamber we cut
off
the basically the loop channel here
but the flow goes around and goes back
down
all right and what happens like part of
the flow goes around the loop channel
a part of the flow goes through the
chamber
in red here and blue for the loop
channel
so what happens is like if you want to
be able to trap
a particle or cell the diameter
of that particle needs to be within
the red flow
okay like depicted here that's why we
developed those zigzag structures
that you could see on the previous
videos
so now if you put a hook
this is the problem here in the first
panel when you put a hook
that you're not going you're going to
prevent what we call the primary
trapping
right no cell would go in now if they
can't get in you've got perfect
secondary trapping
now if you open up a little bit more or
too much
you may get one hundred percent primary
trapping but zero
percent secondary trapping right
so there is a way to get a little bit in
between
not one hundred percent primary trapping
and not zero percent secondary trapping
it's quite inefficient our solution was
the following
basically we add
a pinball system with the hook so
the cell scaling get trapped at 100
and then when it's way out it gets
deflected that this new structure
inside the chamber towards the hook
and basically when the big idea here is
that we break the full reversibility
by inducing cell structure interactions
so let's see how it works in practice
so what you can see in the video you
we've got a bead here which is about
16 micron in diameter gets in
you can see the primary trapping it goes
around the hook
around the second structure now and gets
struck
now when we reverse the flow here by
reversing not just with oil actually
with air the particle got
dislodged and pushed towards the hook
and this and this approach opens up a
new possibility
by using tertiary trapping by the small
hook here
now the initial particle is trapped
so we can bring a second particle in the
system
we get like trapped into the primary
trapping
when we reverse the flow basically
pushed
into the hook as well
actually more a nook here
so you can see by developing this new
design we can do
perfect single cell trapping but
even perfect cell cell pairing or cell
particle pairing
which is really like elusive goal in
microphonic words
so we can see here at work secondary
trapping
that means like the first particle right
again we uh we try to quantify as much
as possible
all the steps so we got about over
90 percent success
and now we've got uh the pairing the
second
particle now which is a cell in white
it's difficult perhaps to see in the
video here but they're getting in
and we got like uh over 92 percent
of trapping the second particle of cell
in this case
sorry in terms of principles uh we broke
the flow reversibility thanks to cell
wall interactions
and in different ways we sell
displacement structures
these are the zigzag structures and you
could see in the different videos
and the pinball structure inside the
chamber that we
really like enable new possibilities
here all right
we can do perfect deterministic uh
cell beat pairing cell self pairing
particular particle pairing
you name it now the next steps we're
working on right now is to
uh show usefulness of this approach to
perform single cell cytokine cytokine
real-time detection
and single cell genomics and epigenomics
and again
at the very high efficiency uh geared
towards like uh
pressure samples that contain between a
few hundreds
typically a few hundred single cells
now i'm going to switch here
to again i mean switch and go back
in time right so go back to the basic
principles and see
what other opportunities we could find
here
so why i mean basically why does it work
how is it possible that we can
encapsulate
from the outlet right and just
focusing on this small channel here
and i mentioned already that uh uh the
fact that we can
inject actually oil or air
uh through the outlet and encapsulate
it's because the second phase
right the air or oil is not going to go
through the small capri
channel because of capillary welding
okay and that is due to laplace pressure
so you've got this interface it doesn't
want to get into a very small
opening it costs too much energy so
that's why it goes around the loop
channel here it's going to close
encapsulate
the chamber from the other side now what
are the new opportunities
here it turns out that
you don't need a plug
you don't need the cell actually right
to be able to perform an encapsulation
so in this case we can create empty
droplets
so it's not necessarily a good thing for
single set genomics
but it opens up new possibilities
because if you can create a
a droplet like this that means you can
create a lot of them
and you can perform digital pcr digital
assays
right so that's that's basically a new
way to perform tropic generation
and the new way we're going to see what
it means
and what are basically the
one of the main problems
in microfluidic in general especially
using arrays of chambers
this is the following we've got a bottle
here
a very simple bottle and we try with a
funnel to fill that bottle
and what you can see is that basically
you cannot fill a bottle
or empty container like this now if you
put a straw
here now it's easy to
fill the bottle and the reason is very
simple
because your empty container is not
empty it contains air
needs to be displaced to be replaced by
water so without the straw the air
cannot be
displaced there is no escape route now
with a straw that creates an escape rod
and then you can feel the button
so if you're in an empty container right
again
it's like empty containers are not empty
but fill the air
and they need to be there needs to be an
escape route for the year
so in microfluidic devices that change
is really solved
by using mostly pdms because gas is
permeable
so the escape route is the material
itself
but now pdms is not cost effective to
large scale manufacturing
on the other hand term plastic is great
because cost effective for large scale
manufacturing
plus cass impermeable right so
and basically you see the question is
like how can we
use thermal plastic to recreate
partitions
or large scale and the answer is like to
use capri valving
to control liquid air interface during
device filling
and this is the type of chamber we've
been using
you've got the main channel horizontal
here
and you got this loop here the chamber
that has a large opening and that
ends up with a few capri channels that
are very thin
so what happens the idea is like we fill
with
let's say a liquid
water in this case right the interface
because we've got interface between
liquid and air comes to
the opening of the chamber and it's
going to get into the chamber
because it has a much wider opening than
the main channel
now it can get into the chamber because
we
created escape route for the air
through the capri channels
and the interface progresses until the
end until it reaches the capri channels
at this point the interface will go back
progressing through the main channel
now once you've got that you can inject
all
from the outlet and based on the same
principle it's going to go
main basically stay within the main
channel
won't go into through the capri channels
and create
a partition
now that is at low capari
number because we harness capri effects
but we can use the same structure at
high capillary number
from the inlet and
this case the progress of the or is
going to depend
on the hydrodynamic resistance so
you have to make sure that your
adrenaline resistance of the main
channel
is lower or much lower than
the ones through your chamber
and these are two ways two modes of
performing
the full encapsulation
so now we've partitioned an array of
4800 chambers
uh and what we basically obtained
take home message here is that we got a
standard deviation that is lower than 10
percent in terms of volume
um these are primary steel primary
results
but still it's good because we need uh
less than 10 percent we know for having
accurate
quantification
so this opens up new perspective
right because we can make those uh
devices in coc imprinted with soft tool
we bonded them with pressure sensitive
tape that is very
easy to manipulate which is really
interesting is like it's quickly
deployable
but in addition it's functionalizable
platform by
by spotting what i mean by this is that
because we use pressure sensitive tape
we don't bond we don't close the
channels
with any thermal treatment
or any solvent that could damage any
things you would
buy a spot with a microarray spotter
such as nucleic acids
or enzymes or proteins so it really
opens up a lot of
applications and we work
on this to make it more robust and
basically
make it like a equipment free
so just to recapitulate our capillary
journey we started with
deterministic single cell encapsulation
and we were as we could actually do
deterministic particle
pairing and encapsulation and now
we exported that further to
develop some digital microfluidic
platform
so now i would like to thank uh people
we
like develop and and uh delivered
all this work for singles encapsulation
we've got doctors
uh suzade and christian and for digital
i say platforming film plastic
dr kwon and mrs maria
alvarez amador and ua young as well as
or
are basically funding agencies
and thank you very much for your
attention i'll be
around to take any questions